you're in so many of our favorite movies
and
i just thought as i'm you know checking
off your imdb
list like literally going is there any
chance we could get a glimpse
of a detail of some of these movies and
some stories in them and we want to try
something called
behind the scenes
[Applause]
um okay a detail an insider fly on the
wall moment
anything that comes to mind when i say
animal house oh my first movie i mean i
was
i was 19. one thing i remember really
well
is the whole experience was completely
overwhelming for me
and my very last shot i was lying in
this in this
uh cutout on the sidewalk and looking up
at this flock of birds
uh floating by and i was just kind of
overwhelmed with
um emotion thinking about the fact that
this
magical experience was about to end but
also that
it was the beginning of a lifetime
uh in in in movies and how grateful i
was for that
one that is so near and dear to our
hearts
diner you know diner was one of those
movies
uh where the experience was so
fantastic and in fact uh me and the
diner guys are still
in touch um we were and we were just
emailing about
some dumb joke that we kind of pass
around between
each other and and uh we really did form
a bond
while we were doing that that movie and
uh i'll never forget it was
it was an amazing experience i mean i
would be remissed if i didn't throw in
although i did
feel like i just got a juicy story about
quincy jones and footloose but
footloose it was uh it was challenging
certainly physically i wasn't trained as
a dancer and
and so try and do those moves and um
and uh but you know again uh
what a what an opportunity and and uh
it's just one of those things that just
uh
changes your life okay i have to include
this
because it's one of the best movies ever
made by none other than john hughes but
please give me a detail about planes
trains and automobiles
well i had done uh
she's having a baby with john and
i knew that his next movie was going to
be planes trains and automobiles
and so i loved working with him so much
that i said to him so listen
man if you got anything at all from me
and and playing trains and autumn deals
i don't care what it is i'll just do it
and he called me up and said i want you
to be an extra at the in the big
movie you're going to race for a cab
with with with steve and
uh and i was like okay that sounds great
um okay well that leads me into
she's having a baby please tell me
something about that
oh wow uh she's having a baby
you know was very intense uh
john worked in incredibly long hours but
i remember um you know he was a giant
music fan john
uh and constantly um
finding bands he had his own record
label and and was
really really uh instrumental in a lot
of young acts
and he had found that kate bush song for
the uh woman
and and uh he played it
uh during the scene where i'm waiting to
find out whether or not
my wife has delivered our our child and
uh and it just hit me every single time
okay one last one a few good men to be
in the company of nicholson
who uh when i started out as a as a kid
he was one of my heroes um the thing i
really loved about
jack and the thing that i've always
tried to sort of emulate is he was one
of the first
actors that i ever saw that seemed as
though
he didn't really care what people
thought of him and yet he was just so
such a movie star uh and such so dynamic
so to be on on the set with him along
with tom and
and to me and you know on and on it was
it was
it was a great experience yeah i i loved
again i loved doing it
drew i mean i'll tell you you know i
when i think back you you name
these movies and all i can think to
myself is about how much i really do
love being an actor and how grateful i
am that i've been able to you know have
these experiences work with these people
and
be able to you know get paid for doing
something that i love so much
i'm so glad you feel that way